- He grew up poor and was
the first in his family
to go to college.
He became Fortune Magazine's 2011
Business Person of the Year.
He's one of the richest men in America
with a net worth of 1.5 billion dollars.
He's Howard Schultz and here are his
top ten rules for success.
- I feel so strongly
that the reason I'm here
is I dreamed big dreams.
I dreamed the kind of dreams
that other people said
would not be possible.
I'm also living proof this
isn't a Hollywood movie.
I come literally from the
other side of the tracks.
If you saw where I grew up
and we took a picture of it,
the neighborhood, the setting.
You say it's not, it's impossible
that someone could come
from there and get here.
But it is possible.
And not to sound too trite
it's possible because
we still live in a country
where the entrepreneurial spirit
is so alive and so well.
And anyone in this country
if you dream big and surround
yourself with great people
and leave your ego at the door
and share a success with others.
And have a little luck along the way
you can do anything.
But there will be people along the way
and I remember this, who will say to you,
you know you're dreaming too big.
It's not possible.
Those things just can't happen.
Don't allow anyone,
friend, family,
acquaintances, teachers
whoever it is, don't
allow anyone to tell you
that what you are dreaming
for yourself and your family
is not possible.
It is possible.
Don't be one of those
people 20 years from now
are going to be walking
around a nine-to-five job
miserable and angry and bitter
because you let your
dreams get away from you.
Because you did not
believe stronger enough,
strongly enough in yourself
and what was possible.
Don't allow that to happen.
This is an unbelievable time.
And I can't encourage
you enough to continue
to think that things are possible
and that your dreams can come true.
How many people have you met in your life
who have said things
like, "I had that idea."
"I knew about that."
Or I, "I was so close but I gave up."
I think sometimes the
difference between success
and failure, winning and
losing, is a very fine line
between those people who'll
continue to move forward.
In August of 87 we had 11
stores and a hundred employees
and a dream to create a
national retail company
around the coffee experience,
good coffee in America.
But there was another dream I had.
And that was to build a
different type of company.
A company that potentially could achieve
the delicate balance between profitability
and the fiscal responsibility
of building shareholder value.
But the balance of also having a heart,
benevolence and integrating
a social conscience
in everything the company would do.
And hopefully one day,
remember this was '87,
the company would be known
as much for its values,
its culture, its guiding principles
as it would the quality of its coffee.
Fast forward from '87
to '89 and '80 and 1990
the company was beginning
to get some traction.
We had about 50 stores.
We still were not making money.
And I think we all realized at the time
that we were not in the
coffee business serving people
but we were in the people
business serving coffee.
That if we wanted to exceed the
expectations of the customer
we had to first exceed the
expectations of our people.
We made a very important
strategic decision early on
that franchising could not maintain
the culture and values of the company.
That all it would be would be
an access to cheap capital.
And so we continued on track
of opening and building
a company owned system.
I've said for years that
that you to celebrate
your victories and really
celebrate your mistakes.
And what I mean by that
is that you have to learn
from the mistakes that you make.
And you've got to create
an environment where
people are not afraid to take a risk
and not afraid to do
things that are beyond
what the expectations are.
At the same time you've
got to set up a framework
for how those things
are managed and judged
and evaluated.
But I believed very
strongly that we could build
a different kind of company.
I never believed, never.
I think it would have
been arrogant to believe
that we could have a thousand, 2,000
or 7,500 stores in the
US and around the world.
But something really
magical started happening
and it started happening as
a result of not advertising
or conventional consumer
classical marketing.
The fact is that Starbucks
spends very little
on traditional advertising.
It started happening because
we demonstrated to ourselves
and now the world that to
build an enduring, sustainable,
long-term business and consumer brand
it's not about fancy marketing.
It's about establishing a
very powerful and unusual
emotional relationship with the customer.
But I'm also here to tell
you that I feel strongly
that long-term value for your shareholders
cannot be achieved in an
enduring sustainable way
unless the management of
the company is completely
and comprehensively committed to creating
long-term value for the employees.
And the two are directly linked together.
And any company, any management team
that turns its back on its people
and doesn't share the
success of the company
with the people who do the work
are not going to finish the race.
I think something that
has happened the last
couple of years that I have noticed
which I think is powerful and it is a
see change is that the consumer
has begun in many ways to perform
what I would call loosely a cultural audit
of companies, of brands,
and of products and services that they are
asked to support, to buy.
And the cultural audit
goes something like,
for the first time businesses recognize
that there is parity in the marketplace.
Parity on price.
Parity on features and benefits.
And the consumer, as a result of that,
has significant choices as to what they're
going to buy and support.
But for the first time
they're asking questions
beyond the characteristics of
the product, or the service.
They're asking about values.
They're asking questions about how you
take care of your people.
Whether or not you're
giving back to the community
in which they live and work.
I think that success in
business is a very difficult
thing to achieve.
And it's more difficult today
probably than any other time
despite the vast number of opportunities.
And as it relates to finding your calling
in terms of what the opportunity
or the entrepreneurial
adventure is going to be
it has to be linked to something
that you are so passionate
and crazed about that you're willing to
knock down walls and climb mountains
and do the things that
are going to put yourself
in a position of sacrificing
so many other things
for its success.
And you can only do that
when there's a compelling
underlying feeling that you have
that this is something I'm
going to fight to the death for.
And without that, I think
it's going to be a commodity
based experience not
only for the customer,
but for you.
And I think that you can't really succeed
at the levels that you want to
unless you find that thing
that you're so passionate, excited,
and in love with.
And I think because you've
got it along the way
you're going to have to
convince so many other people
to believe in you and the
idea and the opportunity
and the struggle and the obstacles that
are going to come can over only be
overcome by this passion that you have
in which you're going to be able to get
people to follow you over those hurdles.
I know it sounds a little bit
sophomoric but it's so true.
This is the key of unlocking
the success of our business
and hopefully the
businesses that you either
are thinking about,
working for, or a part of.
And it's this, it's so basic.
We all want the same thing.
Break break away the differences between
what I just described, language, politics.
The way people dress, their history.
It doesn't matter.
We all want the same thing.
We want to be respected
as employees.
We want to be appreciated as customers.
We want to feel dignified in the workplace
and who we are as people.
And we want to go into a store
and for that brief moment of whether
we're buying a cup of coffee
or whatever it might be,
we want some value for our money.
And the human condition of all of that
between business and the
consumer and everything
everything everything else in between
is the human condition
of the human spirit.
If you can exceed the
expectations of your people,
if they feel they're
working in an enterprise
or a company that values
them as human beings
and not as paychecks values.
Values them as human
beings and not a line-item
on the balance sheet.
And they in turn can take that
feeling of being respected
and appreciated as an employee
and share that with someone else.
A paying customer.
Whether it's in Kuwait or Dubai
or the opening of Starbucks France
where people said it wouldn't be possible.
It can work, and it is sustainable.
Because the human spirit has no language.
And in a time in the world when there is
such cynicism and a fracturing of trust
if you reach out
and appreciate and respect
another human being.
it comes back to you you
Because not every decision
is an economic decision.
Despite the fact that the site statistics
that are narrowing crime
we did provide a 38% shareholder return
over last year.
I don't know how many (mumbling) invested
but I would suspect not many
things, companies, products,
investments, have been termed 38% over
the last couple of months.
Having said that, it is
not an economic decision.
The lens in which we
are making that decision
is through the lens of our people.
We employ over 200,000
people in this company
and we want to embrace diversity
(applause)
If you think respectively,
that you can get a higher
return than 38% you got last year
it's a free country.
You can sell your shares of Starbucks
and buy shares in other
companies, thank you.
(applause)
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Catan JIJ 95 asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile leave it
in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
And I'd also love to know which of the
top 10 lessons from
Howard you love the best.
Leave it below, I'm going
to joining the discussion
and I'll see you soon.